- Ooh! I like the Star card.
- The Star.
- Oh, she's got nice titties.
- There's that card again
we get that all the time.
(laughs)
(upbeat electronic music)
- I guess we met over a decade ago.
We've been dating for about nine years.
- Nine years. Yeah.
- Nine years.
We just got engaged
about three months ago.
- Show your engagement watch.
- This is my engagement watch.
- Just over two years.
- Mm-hmm.
- We've known each other
for probably like 10.
- And we just moved in
together a week ago, so
- Yeah.
- Big changes.
- So my husband was supposed to be here
but his schedule changed at the last time.
Now I'm going to take advantage
of his absence to ask the real questions.
- I never have.
- Never done it before.
- His sister's boyfriend
read my tarot cards.
It was very emotional.
- I actually ran away
and took a nap instead.
- Didn't get much of what was going on
but it's so very much
entrenched in my culture.
(mystical rhythm)
- [Tarot Reader] All right,
let's see what the cards have to say.
- Yeah, okay.
- Yeah.
- We're gonna pull three of
these cards with your left hand
and we'll put them face down right here.
- I see dogs in this one
though, so that's a good sign.
- Oh my god, you guys.
Your first card.
This makes me so happy.
- [Nick] Oh boy.
- This is the card that's like,
there's no more love for either of you.
This is it.
- What?
- [Tarot Reader] All right, okay.
We started with the heart.
- That means I win, right?
- [Tarot Reader] Everything for you guys
is about building the relationship
but it's showing me a
move, which might just be,
do you live together?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, we have to move.
- We're probably moving.
This is a real thing.
- It terms of your relationship, it reads,
oh there's no more big heart break,
she's gone through,
they have to sometimes
work through things,
but there's not,
it doesn't show me like, destruction.
- Oh, this is about babies,
I mean it's about children,
it's about having kids.
(laughs)
Ooh, there you go a
little hint of the future.
- Having children?
Or like getting another dog?
- [Tarot Reader] Maybe there's someone
who's been making life a
little difficult for you and...
Like a woman.
- Ooh.
- [Tarot Reader] I think that's enough
- [Brenda] Could you get her last name?
- It just reads that there's something
about it where maybe there's some jealousy
or something and how you move through this
is going to put you at a better place.
Do you have trip planned together?
- We're going to India.
- Okay, good
Ooh, that's gonna be really good
for the relationship.
Aww, this is my soulmate card.
- No!
- And look, with the little kid
- I see it!
Oh my god! This is so cool.
(mystical rhythm)
Thank you so much.
This is so fun.
- Do you feel good about everything?
- Yes, no, it's super cool.
This is great.
Oh my god, I hope it's positive.
I really do.
- Better
- Yeah?
- Yeah
- Better about what?
- Career, our relationship,
our trip to India
Tarot card reading in general.
- I honestly am shook to my core.
- In a good way?
- Yeah, yeah in a good way.
You know like this was like therapeutic
in ways I never imagined.
- According to the cards,
we're doin pretty well.
- Yeah
- And I think that's great.
- That was a good time.
- So I feel good.
I feel great.
(upbeat electronic music)